we have to have a comprehensive energy
security strategy I refer to it as a
road map and it really has to do with
scientific discovery and technological
innovation and the application of that
in the energy arena and I love to talk
about it and I will in a second but it
also has to do with behavioural change
and behavioural change that is ideal if
people can come to consensus on it but
maybe people have to be incented or
disincentive in certain ways maybe there
has to be a price on carbon two to get
people to think about issues that relate
to climate change
and what ends up happening is some
people believe in climate change I'm one
of them others do not but the irony is
in many ways the same issues that one
has to address for energy security are
ones we need to address for climate
change mitigation what do I mean by that
well the whole scene with respect to
fossil based energy sources is changing
in terms of many more players a race
around the globe for those producer
countries having much more control over
energy supplies these things playing out
in the geopolitical arena fluctuations
and prices of gas at the pump and so on
so if one wants to be less subject to
the vicissitudes of a dedenne evolving
geopolitical landscape and the
vicissitudes of a volatile market then
one has to think in terms of redundancy
of supply but diversity of source and
and so that means we both have to think
about how we get more out of the sources
we already have how do we use them in a
more environmentally benign way for
instance thinking about technologies
like carbon capture and sequestration if
we're using fossil based sources
particularly coal for instance how we
can get more efficiency out of what we
do use such as fuel efficiencies of car
fleets automobile fleets but then how do
we develop new sources of transportation
energy for instance how do we use
conservation to take energy intensity
out of what we do in our daily lives
whether we talk about the use more use
of mass transportation more use of
information technology to control
energy usage in our homes and businesses
etc how do we think about the
development and an investment in new
renewable sources of energy and really
push to the edge in terms of where we
can and should go there so it's not a
one-size-fits-all it's thinking about
yes we're very carbon intense right now
so maybe there needs to be an incentive
true price on carbon to begin to change
behaviors but maybe even as we use such
high carbon content energy sources we
need to think about how we can use less
of them for the same thing and then how
do we mitigate the effects of them with
things like carbon capture and storage
but importantly how do we develop new
resources more electricity based
generation that can depend on things
like wind and solar how do we develop
new biofuels if we think we still need
liquid fuels for a particular kind of
transportation sector for instance the
airline industry I don't think the
airline industry is going to become
purely electrified shortly whereas we
can go a long way in that direction with
ground-based transportation because
range is clearly an issue even for
automobiles if we think of battery
technologies and so we have to push
further on those sorts of undergirding
technologies to be able to have a future
then we have this whole infrastructural
issue we have old infrastructure in this
country it needs to be rejuvenated both
to be more reliable and safe for what we
already use it for but as we do that we
need to think about how do we design it
in a way to put more intelligence
into the grid how do we design it in a
way to be able to attach sources of
energy that have more intermittency
associated with them do we understand
the dynamics and how this these things
affect the stability of the electrical
grid whether it's on a regional basis or
nationally how do we have smart
appliances that can connect to the grid
how does the grid read those but how can
they be really smart enough not just a
dial back on energy use but themselves
can sense some of that dynamics and have
less impact these are really hard
problems but they're very exciting and
important problems and so if we're going
to move to a more electrical
transportation future we got to think
about where that electricity is coming
from how it gets connected into some
broad-based infrastructure that allows
us to create a national system of
transportation and so on and so there
are problems that have to do with new
materials problems that have to do with
modeling and simulation problems that
have to do with new types of computer
controls problems that have to do with
new kinds of devices and so all of these
things if you think about them play
across a broad front involving
mathematics computer science physics all
different fields of engineering and
material science and people even
thinking about using you know more
biologically based organisms to help
clean up things even more biomimetic
processes for manufacturing new types of
things that at nano scales and if we can
push these things that helps as well not
only to come out with important new
tools across all these fronts but it
also actually helps to take energy
intensity out of what we do so
use what we have better use less of it
through conservation and efficiency
that's a big game and they're very
clever things we can do today think
about new propulsion systems new
materials that allow us to have new
propulsion systems and new storage
technologies and ultimately develop and
push the alternative sources of energy
well people are already making a lot of
progress with respect to win energy
there's a lot more in terms of a design
of turbines and new designs that look
more like jet engines as opposed to the
typical windmill but but whichever of
those sorts of things people are
contemplating there's been a lot of work
on structural strength and stability
because of using new types of and
developing new types of composite
materials that lead to better
performance but higher reliability so so
wind is one but but we're going to have
to think about wind differently that's
why people are thinking about new wind
turbine designs because it's not just
about having you know the hundred-acre
wind farm whether it's on land or more
controversially on sea but but that's
that's one example but what people
ironically are doing as well is going
back to almost back to the future and
let me explain that we have a center at
Rensselaer called the center for
architecture science and ecology and
it's a joint venture between us and our
school of architecture and the
architectural firm of Skidmore Owings
and Merrill but the real point is to use
clever use of materials new
nanostructured materials use clever
design of buildings use embedded
technologies to actually bring down the
energy use of a building so for instance
using creating walls that are made of
hydroponic plants that themselves can
suck toxins including of course carbon
dioxide but other toxins out of the air
and and as they they do that they also
help to create and bring down ambient
temperatures use nano structured
desiccant materials
to take humidity out of a building it
depends on the climate one is in use
embedded wind turbines to capture the
barest streams of air convection and use
them to help cool the same building and
to even generate some power so these are
things that people are thinking about
developing new materials for solar
panels that increase their efficiency
and absorptive capabilities in fact one
of our faculty created what we call the
world's darkest material meaning
material that is as far as we know is
the most light absorbent of any material
developed and so that has great
implications when you're thinking about
solar energy also has applications in
other arenas as well
we've been talking about global
population growth the number of people
who live in poverty the people who don't
have access to basic energy and and so
energy security is about having reliable
sustainable non high-cost access to
energy but what people are finding is an
increasing issue has to do with water
and so in the end we're going to end up
having a nested set of issues that
relate to energy climate change water
and health and they play off of each
other it's the phenomenon of what I call
intersecting vulnerabilities and so the
scarcity of water is going to be and
people believe it is already coming
increasingly dominant but again how we
deal with that can come out of the use
of technologies ones that allow people
to have the energy to perhaps purify
water to the sallow need water these are
big big projects but also how one uses
vegetation to preserve water not unlike
this order grand cactus idea but here's
one for you using nano structured
desiccant materials that can draw
moisture out of the air and then have
that come through and drain into some
reservoir to give people potable water
thinking about how one can do cooling
and inherently hot in hostile climates
so in fact there's less water use that
people need how we could lessen the
intensity of our water use which gets
linked as well to the intensity of our
energy use
so as not to use up water how can we
recycle it more so that we don't have to
draw native sources as much these are
critical issues these intersecting
vulnerabilities and if we don't have
those taken care of people cannot be
healthy and we can't have adequate food